made by a a real mexican wife like if
you put these next to them i'm like you
bought these totally
bought those
[Music]
buenos dias mihen thick today is the day
that i decided to attempt at making
bolillos so bolios are this um bread
that is from mexico but i read up on it
and apparently it originated around the
time when the french occupied mexico and
so it's kind of similar to baguettes but
they're smaller yeah so i found this
recipe online by mama latina so you can
find it in the description um she has
amazing recipes they're also in english
and in spanish i've been like stalking
her blog for a long time and i'm like
okay i'm gonna finally get myself to
make one of her recipes because they
look really good and also i've been
trying to really reconnect a lot with my
culture with my mexican culture which
i've talked about a lot i don't know i
guess i find it kind of difficult to
really reconnect with my own culture in
a space where i'm no longer like
surrounded by it anymore because i live
in a different city i have a chinese
husband
my half peruvian half mexican son i have
failed him completely he has absolutely
no ounce of mexican culture in him but
i'm gonna change that and i'm changing
it slowly and definitely for this baby
i'm gonna make sure that this baby grows
up knowing damn well that they are half
mexican so this morning i'm home alone
and i decided to make some breakfast and
this is this reminds me of my my
childhood okay because a lot of us do
this i chopped up some weenies but casey
calls them hot dogs i don't know what do
you guys call them because i call them
weenies so yeah so i chopped up some
weenies and i mixed it with some eggs so
it's eggs and weenies and i'm pairing it
with valentina
another question
for my people out there which hot sauce
do you prefer valentina tapatio
cholula
i can't think of any other ones i
recently went to carnesedia around here
which is like a meat shop like a mexican
meat shop and i just felt myself connect
a lot with my culture and it's something
that i'm severely missing which i don't
really realize until i have it and then
i'm like oh my god i really missed this
anyway at the cardinalia i found
this
so it's
so this is like um chocolate like
chocolate drink for like a mixed drink
but this one i've never seen in a bag so
i'm like oh that's different if you're
mexican you know that it's either ibarra
or abuelita if you've tried both of the
brands which one do you prefer abuelita
or ibarra anyway i got my abelita here
and i made it into like an iced drink
even though it's supposed to usually be
hot
i like my iced drinks so anyway yeah i'm
about to have breakfast and then once i
finish with this breakfast i'm gonna get
to making bolillos so
wish me luck cause i'm really nervous
especially because bread has a mind of
its own casey has attempted making bread
in the past and he failed miserably i'm
sorry honey i love you but you failed
miserably and i hope i don't fail as bad
i hope it's a little bit better i don't
know we'll see anyway
[Music]
okay i just heard casey get home
and i never wake up this early and i
never
make myself breakfast
so i know he's going to be shocked
hi honey did you cook
yeah
you smell good in there
what do you think i make wait we don't
like that look what do you think i mean
uh eggs
oh because you can see the pan yeah eggs
oh it smells like it too it's not like
eggs and i don't know
what's that is that that's not milk what
is that all your mexican stuff mexican
breakfast mexican stuff yeah
i mean without the fact you put
valentina in your
your scramble with the weenies weenies
not hot yeah i mean they could be hot
dogs it's just that i call them weed
right
no what is this i will eat that hot
chocolate or it's not hot
oh that's mom
whatever the cafe the oil tastes like
that kind of tastes like the oils yeah
do you want some
weenies see weenies isn't we knows
yeah and then also i didn't mention this
but the weenies that i bought they're
the brand fud fud but then in spanish we
pronounced it food food i am so
disconnected from my people but not
anymore i'm getting getting freaking i'm
reconnecting all right it is bolio
making time i got some of the stuff out
here already this recipe says it will
take a total of four hours and 20
minutes to complete
and most of that time is because you
have to let the bread rest and like have
the yeast activate and rise and do the
science stuff let me get started i'm a
little nervous to be honest with you you
can't be perfect at the first try of
everything right i need to remind myself
that like i can't be perfect for
everything new that i try because that's
what stops me from trying anything
because i'm like i'm gonna fail it's
gonna suck why even do it i gotta stop
doing that so practice
[Music]
i should point out that this is the very
first time i'm ever needing bread so
this is a new new experience
tell me what i'm doing wrong if you guys
already know okay thank you i would
appreciate the advice
[Music]
all right so i did all that super
nervous because i've been following this
recipe through the video on her website
and the kneading part it did not at all
look like what her video looked like i'm
like
i don't think we're off to a great start
but as of right now i'm supposed to let
the bread rest and it says to put it in
a warm but not hot area that won't get
any drafts or anything so i decided to
put in my pantry
so it's sitting up here
sitting right there and she says to
leave it there for an hour to two hours
until the bread doubles inside or the
flour or the dough or whatever you want
to call it until it doubles in size and
uh it's perfect timing because now i
have therapy so i'm going to do my
therapy i'll see you guys in about an
hour
all right it is one hour later therapy
was good it was a good session it cried
a little bit but you know that's release
anyway i just checked on this dough i'm
a little worried it looks about the same
size to me it says it has to double in
size that doesn't look like it's doubled
i'm really gonna worry but okay let's
just give it another hour let's see
where we're at okay but in the meantime
though i will be making lunch we
recently have been buying
and this is not sponsored by the way but
i've been buying sun basket
so it's a different meal delivery
service today for lunch i'll be making
spicy
tinga tacos with black beans and pico de
gallo so keeping up with the mexican
theme of
today oh you know what i just realized
what a fail
i defrosted the pork for another meal
which is actually
asian it's a vietnamese
dish forget it we're not eating the
tinga tacos because i need to defrost
the chicken so let's put all of these
things back so this one is
turmeric pork
and cabbage salad with vietnamese nut
mom
sauce
nook cham that's how they spelled that
mom isn't it how you you pronounce nook
bomb right oh my god i'm losing it
[Music]
and honestly
screw that freaking pork because when i
was trying to cook it it kept coming out
raw like as i was cutting into it i was
like wait what the hell it's still like
super pink and raw i followed the
instructions and said four to five
minutes on each side and i left it for
five minutes on each side it still came
out raw so i had to cook it again and
then when i cooked it again i grabbed
out these tiny little tongs look at
these these are freaking tiny hey baby
and then because of those tiny
ridiculous tongs which are so cute by
the way i love it but they can't hold on
to anything and i dropped the freaking
pork tumeric pork by the way it's
covered in turmeric and it stained this
uh matte thing so it's like a squishy
squishy kind of matte and it stained it
i guess it doesn't look too bad i guess
maybe i don't know but
i'm really upset about that but whatever
back to the bolillos so it looks like it
definitely did rise i don't know if it
has risen to be double the size but you
know what i did before i put it away i
took a picture of it on my phone
i was like all right that's what it
looks like in the beginning
and then this is what it looks like now
so i'm like
double the size i'm about double but
definitely did expand
alright so
today i finalized gifting my car my
jetta volkswagen jetta to my
mother-in-law tiff's mom and when i met
up with her tis mom gave
me a present which she apparently it's
mexican custom to open presents in front
of the person that gifted you the gift
so i opened it but i wanted a surprise
tiff so i am now going to pass on this
gift so she can open it and i think it's
one of the sweetest
presents i have received since like ever
but here we go all right
are you ready for a present getting a
present yes and your mother gifted this
to our family but
i i was telling the vlog that um i
already opened it because it's mexican
accustomed to open presents in front of
you or the person that gifted you the
present but so here's the surprise for
you bam
oh it's a bear a build-a-bear oh so cute
what is it
oh how cute
look at the pjs oh it's animal crossing
that's so cute
yes
[Applause]
that's so sweet
look at that and you know how you can uh
you can put uh the sound
listen
oh it's so hard
that's so cute oh my god this is making
me cry
oh that's so sweet
i didn't think i would cry
i literally don't ever see myself crying
these days but that's so sweet
oh my god i have to call my mom
given this to me yesterday i saw you
yesterday
oh i love it it's so cute
that's so cute
there's a birth certificate too oh
that's so sweet
stuffed with love by nana there's like
the the birthday yeah yeah it's february
25th
oh that's so cute hopefully they're
bored on that date yeah
i said i was gonna send her your
reaction too i'm gonna i realized i'm
not recording on my phone
i got it's the whole process now they
send her this reaction i have to
casey just gave me the gift and i love
it thank you so much
i
i love
thank you
that's so sweet
you cried
you know what i have expected it to be
her voice with the message oh yeah
but then the fact that it's the baby's
heartbeat
i love it
where is the
speaker
oh is it in the hand i think it's in the
hand oh it is in the hand all right
so listen
it has been way too long way more than
two hours it has risen
oh cool you can see little pockets in
there little holes supposed to be
pockets yeah like bread bread's got
pores bread is porous
all right it's been 20 minutes let's
make some leo shapes now
[Music]
i
tried my best to shape these bolios
listen i'm trying okay
i'm trying this one came out really tiny
i don't think i gave it enough dough now
i have to wait for them to double in
size again
and it's
almost seven o'clock all right it's been
about an hour
since i let these guys rest and this is
the photo i took beforehand
so
they definitely did rise which makes me
happy
but i wouldn't say that they have
doubled in size i don't want to wait
anymore it's 8 o'clock i'm tired i want
to go to sleep but before i go to sleep
i must eat a bolillo so right now i'm
preheating the oven 20 to 22 minutes
of baking and then we have to wait until
they cool down and then we can eat them
can't wait
oh my gosh way too much flour oh no way
too much oh no
[Music]
i put way too much flour
i'm just gonna
blow on them
i mean it's my husband and my son that
are gonna eat these it's fine if it has
a little bit of muscle lemon on there
right it should be okay
oh my god i'm just putting flour
everywhere here okay blowing didn't work
and it's just making a huge mess so
let's try this
there we go
i should have done that in the beginning
[Music]
what just happened
you didn't see that but now i know for
the next time i should just spoon the
flower in the thing and then sprinkle it
not sprinkle and spoon at the same time
you don't do that don't do that you guys
[Music]
all right timer went off
oh
look at that
oh my gosh they look really good okay
i'm low-key kind of proud because they
came out looking so freaking good oh
they look really good and i'm so glad i
dusted off the extra flour that i had
because
damn was it a lot of flour but oh my
gosh
they smell amazing too i wish you guys
could smell it i'm so excited
but they are really small though there's
no way i can make a torta sandwich
out of it but they'll go great with
tomorrow's eggs and weenie this one
looks really good too
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my god
this one's like a breadstick this is
like a tiny little mini bolillo it's so
cute all right i called the boys bolio
time
for real time
close your eyes like isaac i just saw
them oh man keep looking they were
they're obstructed by the other thing
with the pastries okay come on what kind
of song too
come on come on come on nice i didn't
know he was going to close him wait step
stand on the other side really isaac
you're peeking
okay
that open professional yeah made by a a
real mexican wife like if you put these
next to them i'm like you bought these
totally
bought those like you found some baby
that's open in the middle of the night
and then
you're so smart oh wait
no no up there
that one that's mexican hot chocolate
buddy i gotta school you
oh yeah i know this one's actually good
you're starting your day with with the
abuelita and you get to end it with uh
am i saying all right
yeah you're saying you're perfect oh
yeah we get to use these
so isaac bought casey and i a mug for
our anniversary right it was our
adversary right yeah it says number one
mom
and
just dad
better
number one mom with two hearts on each
side and then just dad
you know what though it says serving
size one superhero
huh that's sweet
100 guard uh strength and all this other
stuff you guys can read it and then for
mom it's one super mom
that's cute
[Music]
i'm so excited
let's eat this you guys only you time
okay wait we gotta break the bread come
here break it can you hear the croco
[Applause]
that looks so good
[Music]
okay
it's really good oh my god i'm so
freaking excited i'm freaking proud of
myself this came out good i'm proud of
you mom dude look at this
this is like was that called the middle
part
oh my gosh shout out to mama latina
girl let's collab because you're just
said that was on point
[Music]
it tastes like we bought it at the
bakery
just kidding no no for real be for real
no like serious serious dead serious
don't be nice
don't be a nice guy
i'm not a nice guy i'm a terrible guy
so mean you're so funny and i'm telling
you this is like store-bought oh my gosh
[Music]
good job i want to tell tiff from the
past earlier today in the morning i want
to tell her girl
you did perfect it the very first time
you didn't have to learn any lessons you
were perfect the very first time so
don't even trip
because i talked about being scared
about being perfect oh my gosh i'm so
excited
yeah
soft parts in the middle i don't think
you understand how happy i am because i
was legit preparing for complete and
utter failure and it's not it's actually
really good
success
[Music]
i tried bacon bread twice
failed miserably both times
you come out the gates just succeed
what what
you hit yourself
too much success
[Music]